damon Feldman and bagel boss guy
we're on a judge show you know where
they really went they took each other to
court
JD you got anything to explain cuz he
saw the whole show I think explaining to
me looking fine
so the vid so Damon like crew was able
to prove that she paid bagel boss guy
like all just certain amount of money
how much well like $700 okay and then he
was able to prove somehow that something
with like losing money with like the
pay-per-views or son I didn't write it
didn't go well like two grand or
something so the hot court paid back
Damon two grand well one of them didn't
want to give Damon that much but the
other two judges like they they came
together and and they agreed they a lot
of a [ __ ] is wrong what did your parents
do to you now I know less some money
back all right
Damon got the two grand back Damon got
back like I thought you said it was $700
like last month what do you say bangle
guy Damon Feldman but over $700
you love when JD explained [ __ ] ya know
I could listen to that all day I know
what happened here's the best part of
this if you think about it JD got a
degree in communication what was he like
before I couldn't explain him
I got an associates degree and film and
TV production like did anyone like your
high school go hey dude you're going to
be a communications major you're the
worst at communicating I mean did anyone
like that a guidance counselor get ahold
of you or anybody no I call that much
and probably for good reason
do you think you could do anything about
this now listen what I know something
I'm good at
Jana Katie now it's what are you good at
I just said what do you know what are
you good at I'll answer your question
about it oh I don't know horn what horn
I don't what are you good at I don't
like what would you like me to ask you
have the web camera takes pretty close
well I don't follow all that closely but
I mean I tried feel good with politics
no I know stuff here and there I don't
wouldn't say like I'm an expert at it
you're good at a man in football right
yeah kinda yeah that's good he's gay he
talks about fantasy football a lot he
knows about all the teams ask him
something Gary let's TP Kenny Clinic Dan
JD what's your dilemma this week you're
in the playoffs who are you starting at
quarterback well I got my I got star
Russell Wilson because even though he
sucked this past week because he's been
one of the best quarterbacks a league
but two of my players got injured so I
don't know what I'm gonna do with that I
gotta replace a wide receiver and I I
have a tough schedules with some of them
I faced a Rappaport it's a whole thing
not bad not bad in a bit all right great
but not bad me at least you got a couple
of sentences out all right you know
listen the High Bridge thing happened a
little while ago so what happened the
hot bench thing will happen
I pants however all well here's
something you know about let's see how
you uh tell me with with detail why is
filet-o-fish the best sandwich ever
well uh I like fish I like fish and it's
got tartar sauce and the mixture is very
good the bun did the bun they have with
it is very good so that's you know it
goes down easy you know what I like fish
I like fillets I like the letter all
right what's to think about
goes down easy all around Agee comes
outta here